Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim. Wir machen das immer morgens. Das kann man ja auch mal ruhig sagen. Montag morgens.
Ja, Montag morgens, wenn man ganz frisch ist.
Ja, du vielleicht.
Du hast länger geschlafen als ich.
Ja, das stimmt. Ich hab mir Mühe gegeben. Ich hab extra früh ins Bett gegangen.
Ich finde, so komplexe Sachen kann man morgens eigentlich auch viel besser bearbeiten. Du bist dir nicht so sicher. Na ja, immerhin, du hast jetzt hier auch wieder auf Oldschool Notiztechnologie umgeschaltet, wie ich sehe.
Ja, einen Blog habe ich genommen, aber das ist nichts für mich.
Ein Blog, hast du es geblockt auf einem Papierblock? Ja, sehr hübsch, aber ist nicht so toll. Kein Copy und Paste.
Das muss man dann doch so analog einzeichnen, so Pfeile, Klammern, dann hier. Interessante.
Kann auch Vorteile haben. Wie auch immer, wir begrüßen euch alle hier zur dritten Ausgabe von Logbuch Netzpolitik, Tim Pritlove und Linus Neumann. Und Linus, worüber reden wir denn heute?
Heute reden wir über Twitter, wie man das ja so macht. In selbstreferenziellen Netzpodcasts redet man über Twitter. Aber in diesem Fall...
Und auf Twitter redet man über den Podcast.
In diesem Fall über die Entscheidung der Herausgabe von Daten bei Twitter und so ein bisschen das Umfeld, in dem das da steht. Und dann wollen wir noch so ein bisschen kurz Ausblick über eine Entscheidung der Federal Trade Commission, eine Einigung mit Facebook, irgendwie darauf einen Ausblick geben und den American Censorship Day ankündigen.
Okay, ja dann bleiben wir doch mal gleich bei Twitter. Da geht es um Wikileaks und um Wikileaks ging es ja auch schon in der letzten Sendung. Was ist denn da jetzt die neue Entwicklung?
Ja, die neue Entwicklung ist, dass Twitter jetzt tatsächlich auch in zweiter Instanz entschieden wurde, dass Twitter also Daten über bestimmte Personen rausgeben soll an US-Behörden. Das hatte also schon eine etwas längere Vorgeschichte. Der ganze Fall ist eigentlich schon ein Jahr bald alt. Das ging irgendwie los am 14. Dezember letzten Jahres, als Twitter also einen Brief bekam von US-Behörden, in dem es hieß, sie sollten bitte bestimmte Daten über Personen rausgeben. Namentlich waren das Wikileaks Julian Assange, Birgitta Jonsdottir, eine isländische Parlamentsabgeordnete, die sich dort in enger Zusammenarbeit mit Wikileaks für diese Icelandic Modern Media Initiative eingesetzt hat, also ein Gesetzesvorstoß, der da die Rechte von Pressepublikationen stärken soll und außerdem auch sonst eng mit Wikileaks zusammengearbeitet hat. Rob Hrongraib, habe ich das jetzt richtig ausgesprochen?
Hrongraib, ja.
Rob Hrongraib, ein niederländischer Hacker, ist er CCC-Mitglied? Er hat auf jeden Fall die Keynote öfter mal gehalten, glaube ich.
Ob er jetzt auf dem Papier tatsächlich da eine Mitgliedschaft hat, das kann ich dir gar nicht sagen, aber ich meine, das ist ja beim CCC egal. Also Rob ist einer der wichtigsten Persönlichkeiten, eigentlich in der europäischen und internationalen Hacker-Szene überhaupt und ich hatte ihn ja auch hier schon mal bei Chaos Radio Express zu Gast. Lustigerweise auch genau eine Woche bevor eben diese Twitter-Geschichte dann wirklich losging. Hab ja auch kurz mit ihm geredet über diese ganzen, über so seine Sicht, warum er sich da bei Wikileaks überhaupt engagiert hat, insbesondere für dieses Collateral Damage Video, mit dem das ja irgendwie alles losging. Entschuldigung, ja, Collateral Murder natürlich.
Genau, Rob und ja, vielleicht noch kurz zum Hintergrund, der hat ja doch glaube ich den ersten holländischen ESP gegründet, ne?
Also Rob ist in vielerlei Hinsicht da Pionier gewesen und unter anderem gehört er eben auch zu den Leuten, die Excess For All gegründet haben. Irgendwann haben sie es dann halt verkauft.
Genau, Rob und dann Bradley Manning wollten sie auch noch die Daten von haben und wen habe ich jetzt vergessen? Jacob Applebaum wahrscheinlich auch. Und ja, Jacob Applebaum, Torentwickler und Wikileaks.
Aktivist.
Aktivist, Unterstützer.
Und auch generell Aktivist. Dem habe ich übrigens auch schon mal ein Interview gemacht. Lange ist es her. Und zwar an einem anderen Kanal und zwar dem Chaos Radio International. Oder hatte ich es nicht sogar auch bei Chaos Radio Express mit drin? Das muss ich gleich mal schauen. Ah ja, stimmt. Chaos Radio Express 13. Das ist schon eine Weile her. Das ist von 2005. Da bin ich überhaupt das erste Mal auf ihn aufmerksam geworden, weil er sich seinerzeit beim Hurricane Katrina eingesetzt hat. Und da wirklich vor Ort war, in New Orleans. Und dann hatten wir da irgendwie so einen Moment of Future, wo er dann so in dem zerstörten New Orleans, so ohne Strom, nur auf Akku mit seinem Powerbook und irgendeinem Modem, so einem 3G Modem irgendwie war und dann seine Webcam an den Start gebracht hat und wir dann irgendwie im CCC noch im Streaming-Server bereitgestellt haben, so auf Zuruf. Und das war wirklich irre. Also so aus der Dunkelheit von New Orleans kamen dann auf einmal so schämenhafte Bilder gestreamt und wir waren in der Lage, die irgendwie mal eben über den ganzen Planeten zu verteilen. Das war schon echt speziell. Und naja, und da habe ich irgendwie das erste Mal ausführlich so mit ihm, mit seinem Hintergrund geredet und er ist einfach jemand, der das wirklich auch alles wirklich verdammt ernst nimmt und der also wirklich für die Sache kämpft und darüber hinaus auch noch ein ausgesprochen talentierter Mensch. Das ist in vielerlei Hinsicht ja nicht nur ein guter Hacker, sondern auch ein Fotograf und so weiter. Da wollten sie also nun ran an die Daten, das Government. Und haben bei Twitter angeklopft und normalerweise ist es ja eigentlich so, dass diese Firmen darüber nicht reden dürfen.
Genau, das ist also eine sehr schöne Konstruktion, die die USA da haben. Das geht zurück auf ein Gesetz aus dem Jahre 1986, den Electronic Communications Privacy Act. Also ein Gesetz aus einer Zeit, als das World Wide Web noch gar nicht gab. Und in diesem Gesetz wird im Prinzip festgelegt, dass so Kommunikationsanbieter Daten rausgeben sollen. Und die Hürde, die dabei gelegt wird, ist, dass es reasonable grounds geben muss, also begründete Annahmen und nicht, wie das eigentlich bei Durchsuchungen in den USA eigentlich notwendig ist, dieses probable cause. Also probable cause, wie übersetzt man das auf Deutsch am besten?
Ein möglicher Anlass?
Ja, aber man muss einen wirklich einen sinnvollen Grund haben, um eine Hausdurchsuchung zu machen. Und nicht einfach nur eine Vermutung.
Also ein berechtigter Verdacht.
Berechtigter Verdacht, genau, das ist, glaube ich, die beste. Und reasonable grounds ist also eine sehr viel niedrigere Schwelle und eben auch so ein bisschen schwammiger. Und im Moment, das nur am Rande wird gegen dieses, genau gegen dieses Gesetz, unter anderem Lobby betrieben von Google Microsoft AT&T, weil sie also sagen, dass das nicht mehr, nicht mehr angemessen wäre. Also auf Basis dieses Gesetzes fragen dann Behörden bei Providern an und sagen, wir hätten gerne diese und jene Daten. Und weil es ja irgendwie mit unserem, mit dem Ziel unserer Ermittlungen interferieren könnte, dürft ihr mit niemandem darüber reden. Gebt uns bitte die Daten und die Sache ist erledigt. So ein Brief geht also im Dezember letzten Jahres bei Twitter ein. Also man nennt das Gag-Order. Also diese Gag-Order heißt also Verschleierungsbefehl. Sie dürfen mit niemandem darüber reden. Und Twitter hat als erstes mal erfolgreich dagegen geklagt, dass sie nicht darüber reden dürfen. Weil dadurch, dass sie darüber reden, durften sie erst mal dann die betroffenen Personen darüber informieren, um denen wiederum erst mal die Möglichkeit zu geben, sich gegen diese Entscheidung überhaupt zu wehrzusetzen und dagegen zu klagen. Das heißt also, wenn das Ding nach Plan verläuft, dann gibt Twitter diese Daten raus, oder wer auch immer diesen Brief kriegt, gibt die Daten raus und redet niemals mit irgendjemandem darüber. Das ist so der Plan. Vielleicht hier kurzer Seitenverweis auf Nicholas Merrill, der den New Yorker ASP Kelligs gegründet hatte oder CEO auf jeden Fall davon war und schon vor vielen Jahren nämlich genauso einen Gag-Order hatte und Daten herausgeben musste. Und der hat auf dem 27C3 einen sehr langen Vortrag darüber gehalten, den wir auch mal in den Show Notes verlinken werden. Was da so seine Erfahrungen waren und wie er damit umgegangen ist, welche Daten er da rausgeben muss. So viel mal zum Thema Gag-Order. Gut, dann sind wir also so weit. Twitter wehrt sich dagegen, dass sie nicht darüber sprechen dürfen und informiert dann, weil sie sich ja dann nicht mehr strafbar machen, informiert dann öffentlich darüber, dass diese Daten angefordert sind. Worauf hindern Birgitta, Rob, Jacob und Bradley Manning hat es, glaube ich, nicht gemacht. Und ich weiß nicht, inwiefern Wikileaks sich da noch mit befasst hat. Von EFF, der Electronic Frontier Foundation, der großen Bürgerrechtsbewegung, die wir ja schon mal erwähnt haben in den USA für digitale Bürgerrechte und der American Civil Liberties Union, die noch ungleich sehr viel größere Bürgerrechtsbewegung der USA. Die haben also dann Anwälte gestellt und sich irgendwie gegen diesen Befehl gewehrt. Und jetzt muss man, also der Verdacht war damals schon sehr klar, dass der Brief nicht nur an Twitter gegangen ist, sondern auch an viele andere. Unter anderem stellte sich dann nach einiger Zeit auch raus, dass deiner dort der Domain-Registrar, der die Wikileaks-Domain für Wikileaks verwaltet hat, so einen Brief bekommen hat. Und wie sich dann rausstellte, bekam Google auch einen. Was da drin verlangt wird, ist, sie wollen den Anmelde, Nutzer und Screenen haben, alle Kontaktinfos, also postalisch, E-Mail, Telefonnummern und so weiter, alle Verbindungsdaten mit Zeit und Dauer, die Nutzungsdauer generell, also seit wann man da überhaupt einen Account hat, und Telefon- oder ID-Nummern inklusive dynamischer IPs, also wie hat er irgendwie mit uns kommuniziert. Twitter könnte man ja auch über Telefon nutzen. Und den Payment Service und die Billing Records, also wie hat er bei euch bezahlt und gebt uns mal bitte die Rechnung, die ihr dem geschrieben habt. Das war ja schon etwas, das gibt's ja bei Twitter nicht, womit die Frage irgendwie relativ, oder es relativ offensichtlich wurde, dass das ein Serienbrief ist, den Twitter da bekommen hat. Leuchtet ja auch ein, dass wenn ich irgendwie an WikiLeaks will, ich nicht unbedingt bei Twitter anfange, was dann relativ, als One-to-many-Medium irgendwie relativ uninteressant ist. Naja, dann ein- und ausgehende Verbindungen mit Datum, Zeit, Dauer, Art, Volumen, Nutzernahme, Quell- und Ziel-IP. Alle weitere nichtinhaltliche Info, Briefwechsel, also einfach mal einmal alles. Und wie sich also dann dagegen gewehrt wurde, war das gesagt wurde, naja, ihr wollt IP-Adressen. Und diese IP-Adressen ermöglichen so eine Geolokation. Also je nachdem, welche IP ich habe, kann man ja sehr stark eingrenzen, wo ich mich befinde. Und das würde gegen das vierte Amendment der USA verstößen, nämlich Unreasonable Search and Seizure. Ein wichtiger Teil bei den USA, dass sie sagen, wir verbieten per Verfassung willkürliche und unangemessene Untersuchungen und schützen so den privaten Raum. Damit sind sie in erster Instanz schon im März, glaube ich, dann gescheitert und jetzt auch noch in zweiter Instanz. Und jetzt muss Twitter diese Daten rausgeben. Also Urteil lautete keine Verletzung des vierten Amendments und keine besondere Verletzung des Datenschutzes. Und damit kommen diese Daten. Ein paar Wochen vorher ging es durch die Medien, dass bei Jacob Applebaum das gleiche Ding eben mit Google gemacht wurde, wobei da irgendwie noch nicht so ganz klar gesagt wurde, ob Google die Daten jetzt rausgegeben hat oder nicht. Aber irgendwie sieht es ja danach aus. Und man kann also nur spekulieren, wer noch alles solche Briefe bekommen hat. Man kann sich eben natürlich auch denken, was das insgesamt bedeutet, wenn überhaupt die USA solche Gesetze haben und sowas möglich ist. Und wir werden sehen, wie man sich irgendwie dagegen wehren kann. Und auf jeden Fall zeigt das aus, wie viel Vertrauen eben solchen Anbietern.
Das zeigt natürlich auch schön, was möglich wäre, wenn der Mut bei den amerikanischen Unternehmen vielleicht auch noch einen Funken stärker ausgeprägt wäre. Ich meine, man fragt sich natürlich sofort, warum nur Twitter? Ich komme jetzt gerade nicht auf den Namen, aber ich glaube, die Person, die bei Twitter jetzt konkret dafür zuständig war, ist auch jemand, der so ein bisschen EFF etc. Hintergrund hat und von daher als engagierter Jurist ohnehin bekannt war. Ich habe mal einen Artikel dazu gelesen, habe aber jetzt gerade den Link nicht parat. Deswegen komme ich jetzt auch nicht auf den Namen. Schauen wir mal, wenn wir den noch finden, dann packen wir den in die Show Notes. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr interessante Person und der hat das dann auch wahrscheinlich sehr persönlich genommen an der Stelle. Beziehungsweise sah es eben auch als, das ist jetzt ein bisschen meine Unterstellung, aber selbstverständlich merkt man auch, dass die Unternehmen auch in den USA, die da immer ganz gerne so Nachlässigkeit gegenüber, Datenschutz etc. vorgeworfen wird, dass das für sie auch ein Problem ist. Also ich denke nicht, dass das ein unerkanntes Problem ist. Die sehen schon, dass das Vertrauen, was die Nutzer an ihrer Plattform haben, in zunehmendem Maße wichtig wird. Es gibt ja jetzt auch so eine Initiative verschiedener Unternehmen. Ich glaube, da sind irgendwie alle Großen mit drin, einschließlich Facebook und auch Apple, die halt jetzt gegenüber dem Government auch sagen, wir hätten jetzt hier auch ganz gerne mal so ein bisschen verbindlichen Schutz, dass wir nicht einfach beliebig hier ausgeplündert werden können, weil das trägt dazu bei, dass die Leute uns nicht vertrauen. Und wenn die Leute uns nicht vertrauen, dann nutzen sie unsere Dienste nicht. Und wenn sie unsere Dienste nicht nutzen, ist es einfach nicht gut für unser Business. Und was nicht gut für unser Business ist, ist nicht gut für alle etc.
Halt das wirkliche.
Und das ist ja eigentlich auch sehr schön, dass diese Erkenntnis langsam reift, auch wenn man wirklich den Eindruck hat, dass sie langsam reift. Ich denke jetzt nicht, dass auf dieser Twitter-Sache wirklich viel bei rauskommen wird.
Nein, nein, Twitter ist eigentlich völlig uninteressant. Ja, ich meine, Twitter, ja, was haben die schon, ja, okay.
Direct Messages vielleicht, wenn die wirklich das mal benutzt haben, was ich ehrlich gesagt bezweifle.
Das, was wirklich... Also interessant ist eigentlich eher eben die Annahme, dass es ganz offensichtlich ist, wer das noch alles, wer noch solche Briefe bekommen hat. Und das war ja auch von... Also das Vorgehen von EFF und ACLU waren drei Anträge, wo sie eben gesagt haben, als allererstes wollen wir wissen, wer noch solche Anträge alles bekommen hat. Das war der erste Antrag. Und der zweite war dann eben, okay, wir wollen, dass diese nicht gültig sind. Und die allererste Forderung war überhaupt erst mal dieses Gagging, das eben zu verbieten oder aufzuheben. Und den Antrag haben sie im Prinzip unbearbeitet, abgelehnt zurückbekommen. Jetzt kann man sich natürlich denken, wer noch alles solche Dinge bekommen hat. Und bei Twitter ist es ja noch uninteressant, bei Gmail wird es natürlich spannender. Wobei auch da davon auszugehen, ist das Jacob jetzt nicht unbedingt der Gmail-User ist. Der Gmail-User ist, der seinen ernsten Kram darüber macht. Aber auch da, wenn es dann irgendwie darum geht, alle eingehenden und ausgehenden Verbindungen, dann kann das eben, sagen wir mal dummerweise dazu führen, gerade bei WikiLeaks haben sich ja sehr viele Freiwillige immer gemeldet und ihre Hilfe angeboten. Und wenn man jetzt mal davon ausgeht, dass da vielleicht irgendwelche Menschen dabei waren, die ja vielleicht nicht ganz so schlau waren, oder vielleicht relativ offene E-Mails dahingeschrieben haben oder versucht haben, ihn zu kontaktieren, dann sind das natürlich Menschen, wo man gerne mal reinschaut. Wohlgemerkt, der Inhalt der Kommunikation ist nicht davon betroffen, von diesen Orders, aber quasi das Erstellen eines Profils, wer hat den kontaktiert, mit wem ist der in engeren Kontakt oder so. Das sind natürlich schon relativ mächtige Daten, wenn man die über viele Jahre von Personen hat.
Es füllt dann vor allem das Bild. Und selbst wenn der Inhalt jetzt nicht so das Ding ist, wir wissen ja gerade bei Überwachung, gerade dieses wer mit wem ist ein Ding. Kommuniziert man mit jemanden überhaupt, dann kann man einfach schon nicht mehr behaupten, dass man jemanden nicht kennt. Oder es wird irgendeine Relevanz daraus abgeleitet, die vielleicht so gar nicht existiert, aber wo man dann eben auch schlechte Karten hat.
Also insgesamt ein Unding, dieses Gesetz. Und ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich kann mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen, dass das irgendwie bestehen bleibt. Eigentlich sind die ja gerade die Verfassung in den USA, da legen sie ja relativ viel Wert drauf. Und ich bin eigentlich, also mich überrascht das tatsächlich, vor allem weil in meinen Augen das relativ offensichtlich, dieses vierte Amendment, ganz klar in seinem Zweck verletzt. Interessante Sache.
Ja, National Security hat einfach in den USA eine Bedeutung und ist auch so ein bisschen das Totschleitargument. Das ist natürlich auch bei uns eigentlich nicht anders. Nur, dass halt hier die Privacy- und Datenschutzkeule einfach viel, viel, viel größer ist, mit der zurückgehauen wird. Und diese Auseinandersetzung, die ist ongoing. Trotzdem habe ich so den Eindruck, dass die Dinge sich langsam ändern, auch in den USA. Und wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe, ist unser nächstes Thema. Geht auch so ein bisschen in die Richtung, oder?
Das wollte ich nur so als kleines Side Note geben. Das ist also Facebook steht da gerade in Verhandlungen mit der Federal Trade Commission über bestimmte Regelungen dieses Dienstes. Da weiß man noch nichts genaues. Da sind jetzt erste Gerüchte rausgekommen. Und es sieht so ein bisschen danach aus, dass Facebook sich erstens darauf zu einigen scheint, dass es so ein Opt-in geben soll. Oder etwas, was zumindest interpretiert werden kann als eine Opt-in-Regelung. Also Opt-in hatten wir ja gesagt, hatten wir glaube ich schon mal besprochen, als es so ein Post-Privacy ging, dass Facebook neue Features einführt, seine AGBs entsprechend ändert, einfach nur kurz sagt, okay, stimme mal zu. Oder du kannst den Dienst nicht weiter nutzen, hier sind die 50 Seiten, liest die mal bitte eben. Und jetzt, guck mal hier, jetzt haben wir schön Gesichtserkennung. Und dass das eben dazu führt, dass diese Features sehr viel leichter eingebaut werden können.
Genau, das ist eigentlich opt-out. Man muss halt sagen, nein, ich will es nicht, sonst hat man es.
Man stimmt dann erst den neuen Daranschutzbedingungen zu, oder so, wenn es da überhaupt noch welche gibt. Und dann hat man dieses Feature. Und jetzt soll es eben sein opt-in. Das heißt, sagen, guck mal hier, wir haben Gesichtserkennung, möchtest du das auch haben? Und das Ergebnis wäre natürlich denkbar an das verteilte Häufigkeit. Dass die Leute eher sagen, nee, lass mal bitte weg. Das könnte also sein, und sie verpflichten sich zu 20 Jahren unabhängigen Datenschutz- und Privacy-Audits. Aber das sind wie gesagt erst mal nur Gerüchte. Und das wird also mal interessant. Wenn da was rauskommt, dann könnte das echt mal einen sehr großen Effekt haben.
Und das geht von der Federal Trade Commission aus.
Ich denke, dass die sich eingeschaltet haben. Facebook wird sich ja nicht freiwillig an die gewendet haben.
Jungs, wollt ihr uns mal reglementieren?
Das gab es schon öfter mal. Bei Twitter haben die das auch mal gemacht. Und bei anderen Diensten gab es dann auch ein paar Absprachen. Und vor allem diese Independent Audits, da kümmern sie sich irgendwie drum. Aber wie gesagt, das jetzt nur mal so am Horizont könnte interessant werden. Und viel spannender wäre eben dann das dritte Thema der American Censorship Day. Der wird also ausgerufen von EFF, Public Knowledge, Free Software Foundation und auch da wieder allen großen Netz-Szene-Organisationen, die also am Mittwoch Webseiten ausschalten wollen, bieten da so ein kleines Skript an, baut man in seine Webseite ein und am Mittwoch an diesem Mittwoch, Mittwoch der 16. November und dann gibt es 2011, 2011.
Diese Sendung werden ja auch in 500 Jahren noch gehört.
Richtig.
Da muss man schon mal ein bisschen Kontext bieten.
Genau. Und da geht es jetzt um den SOPA, den Safe Online Piracy Act, der da im House of. Ja, genau, da kommt jetzt ein, kommt also aus dem House of Representatives und da verlangt also ein House-Mitglied, also Member of the House, dass wir, dass es also so ist, dass man, wenn eine Seite auf die US abzielt, auf die USA abzielt, also eine Zielgruppe hat, die sich in den USA befindet und Urheberrechte verletzt oder aber, das ist eine sehr schöne Formulierung, es vermieden hat eine hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit von Urheberrechtsverletzungen zu bestätigen. Das heißt also, es wären dann diese Seiten links auf Urheberrechtsverletzungen. Also es wäre dann, sagen wir mal, es gibt ein Forum, in dem häufiger links auftauchen, die auf urheberrechtlich relevante Sachen zeigen.
Also was wie The Pirate Bay.
Ja, oder Pirate Bay oder Foren, die es vermieden haben, diese hohen Wahrscheinlichkeiten zu prüfen. Dann soll in Zukunft es möglich sein, dass man als Besitzer dieses Urheberrechts einen Notice irgendwo hinschickt und dann haben die Payment Provider dieser Seiten fünf Tage Zeit, bis sie ihnen den Geldhahn abdrehen müssen. Die betroffenen Seitenbetreiber können einen Widerspruch einreichen innerhalb dieser fünf Tage. Dieser Widerspruch muss aber nicht unbedingt anerkannt werden, weil solange es irgendwie eine sinnvolle, begründete Annahme gibt, dass dort eine Urheberrechtsverletzung stattfindet, sind die Payment Provider fallen raus. Das heißt, die haben eher ein Problem, wenn sie dieser Notice widersprechen, als wenn sie sie einfach durchführen, weil wenn sie es durchführen, haben sie keinerlei Verbindlichkeiten gegenüber demjenigen, dem sie da den Geldhand zugedreht haben.
Also im Prinzip die WikiLeague-Story nochmal.
Genau, die WikiLeague-Story jetzt mal schön.
Weil man gemerkt hat, dass das zickt ja irgendwie richtig an einer interessanten Stelle. Damit kann man jetzt vielleicht auch alles andere auch noch mit aushebeln.
Genau. Und dann noch so klassischer Kram. DNS-Provider, dass also die DNS-Einträge manipuliert werden müssen, damit diese Seiten nicht mehr aufrufbar sind. Und Suchmaschinen ebenso.
Gute Güte. Und dagegen wendet sich der American Censorship Day.
Genau, der American Censorship Day richtet sich dagegen, dass dieses SOPA-Teil irgendwie sich da durchsetzen soll. Und was dann noch bei Kirsten, bei Netzpolitik, geschrieben, dass es außerdem, wer Programme entwickelt, wie z.B. Tor oder Browser-Erweiterung oder Mittel aufzeigt, wie z.B. die Veröffentlichung von IP-Adressen, die zur Umgebung von DNS-Sperren dienen könnten, macht sich ebenfalls strafbar. Das habe ich jetzt so dann bei der IFF nicht rausgelesen, aber zitiere ich mal so. Also man könnte wirklich sagen, ein Gesetz, was wenn es so zum Einsatz kommt in USA, echt das Internet vollständig kaputt machen könnte.
Ja, vor allem in der Geldhahn. Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendetwas davon steht, was die Payment-Provider davon halten. Ich meine, jetzt sind wir wieder schon im nächsten Bereich, wo das Vertrauen der Kunden, bei PayPal ist ja ohnehin so das Ding, dass man eben sich überhaupt nicht sicher sein kann. Das ist ja jetzt gar nicht mal nur, wenn man jetzt hier zu den derzeit anerkannten internationalen Terroristen gehört, dass man da was befürchten muss. Sondern es ist ja so generell so, dass wenn da die Algorithmen zuschlagen und sagen, hier ist irgendeine Geldbewegung im Gange, die verstehen wir nicht. Und das ist ja häufig bei solchen Fällen. Wir hatten den Fall neulich mit Diaspora, die nach Spenden gerufen haben. Und auf einmal kommt dann halt ganz viel Geld von ganz vielen Leuten. Und dann sehen die das einfach als, keine Ahnung, was sie das überhaupt klassifizieren, aber in irgendeiner Form als unangemessenes Nutzerverhalten. Und machen halt ne Sperre des Kontos, die dann eben auch teilweise ein halbes Jahr aufrechterhalten werden.
Die bei dem Modell von PayPal natürlich noch den Vorteil dazu hat, dass das Geld ja im Besitz von PayPal bleibt und sie damit dann ja Zinsen, Spekulationen und sonst was irgendwie anstellen können. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ich habe jetzt erst mal bei meinen Recherchen noch keine Stellungnahmen von Payment-Providern gefunden, was nicht heißen soll, dass es keine gibt. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie die dazu stehen.
Ja, aber es wäre mal ganz interessant, das herauszufinden. Es wäre auch vor allem interessant, das herauszufinden, wie eigentlich mal die wenigen und sicherlich noch weitgehend unbedeutenden, aber nichtsdestotrotz auch existierenden Payment-Provider in Deutschland das sehen. Weil das sind natürlich auch Bewegungen, wir wissen ja alle, wenn das in den USA erst mal als gangbarer Weg angesehen wird, dann gibt es auch hier immer eine Front von Leuten, die der Meinung sind, ach so, hier wieder eine neue Keule zum draufhauen, prima. Weil es muss ja was getan werden gegen den internationalen Terrorismus und überhaupt. Weil da noch Kinderpornografie noch mit dazu kommt.
Ganz wichtig, natürlich wird dieses Ding hauptsächlich damit begründet, dass jetzt die neue Story in den USA, dass mit diesen Copyright-Verletzungen Terrorismus finanziert wird. Das ist ja, also das hatte ich noch kurz zu Ende.
Ja, ja, und ich meine, es ist so ein bisschen so, Heizung und Strom abdrehen, das sind schon so sehr unzumutbare Dinge. Geldhahn abdrehen ist in gewisser Hinsicht noch viel schlimmer. Und wenn sich das jetzt einfach durchsetzt, so als vor allem ja auch zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo eigentlich noch gar nichts klar ist. Hier werden nur von einer Seite Forderungen aufgestellt mit unserer Meinung nach läuft da was falsch. Es gibt hier keinen Gerichtsbeschluss oder so im einlichen Sinne. Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, ist das ja hier auch so quasi erst mal so als präventive Maßnahme gedacht. Na ja, erst mal so als vorübergehende Maßnahme ruinieren wir sie. Und danach schauen wir mal, was eigentlich wirklich passiert ist. Und das kann ja wohl nicht ihr Ernst sein, aber wir wissen...
Das meinen die total Ernst.
Das meinen die total Ernst, ja.
Also wir werden sehen, wie sich das durchsetzt. Also was die USA ja eh schon seit einiger Zeit machen, sind eben so diese Webseiten, Domain Name Sieges, Beschlagnamen, also Domains. Das gibt es jetzt schon ein paar hundert Fälle von, wo dann irgendwelche Server vom einen oder anderen Tag auf einmal weg waren und dann so ein schönes Siegel da drauf hatten, wo dann eben auch genau das passierte, dass dann die beschlagnahmende Instanz natürlich auch mitgeloggt hat, wer kommt denn da an, an Besuchern und so. Also da wird es gerade sehr interessant, sehr spannend und kann man also nur hoffen, dass es irgendwie gelingt, das irgendwie zu verhindern. Ja, weil also gerade auch dieser Missbrauch, ja es kann ja dann so sich zum Samstagabend-Scherz entwickeln, irgendwelche Seiten abzuschalten. Da schreibe ich halt selber bei irgendeinem ins Forum einen Link zu einer Copyright-relevanten Seite und schreibe dann auch selber direkt die Beschwerde und fünf Tage später ist die Seite raus. Also das, man kann ja sagen von mir aus, dass es irgendwie ein Problem mit Urheberrechtsverletzungen gibt und es ist ja auch, in der Tat hat ja auch jemand, der vom Gesetz irgendwie geschützt wird, den Anspruch darauf, dass ihm da zu seinem Recht verholfen wird. Da muss man sich eben überlegen, ob man dann die Gesetze ändert. Was aber nicht geht, sind natürlich so dermaßen Eingriffe und dann auch hier wieder den Richtervorbehalt weglassen, der auch schon nicht so viel bringt. Der ohnehin schon nichts bringt, aber den dann auch noch rauszunehmen, wird also eine interessante Angelegenheit. Also da nicht wundern, wenn eure Lieblingswebseiten in den USA am Mittwoch dann mal nicht funktionieren. Große Petition und eben dieser Begriff des Wortes Zensur ist in den USA sowieso auch sehr ungern gehört. Also sie sollten eigentlich mit dieser Kampagne hoffentlich sehr viele Leute mobilisieren können. Kann man nur hoffen, dass sie diesen SOPA und auch den Protect IP Act, der ähnliche Sachen mit ähnlichen Forderungen im Senat seit einiger Zeit liegt, dass sie das irgendwie hoffentlich vom Tisch kriegen.
Mit IP ist in dem Fall wahrscheinlich Intellectual Property genannt. Genau, nicht das, was hier vielleicht manche glauben.
Der Protect IP Act geht häufig mehr so über, da wird häufig auch von Fälschungen gesprochen und von der Gefahr von Menschen und durch gefälschte Medikamente. Ähnlich wie ACTA, das Anti-Counterfeit Trade Agreement, was ja so dieser geheime Welt, der geheime Weltvertrag irgendwie zu sein scheint, der da irgendwie in Planung ist über schnelleren Austausch, in Fälle solcher schnellerer Austausch und vereinfachter Austausch von Informationen, länderübergreifend zur Verfolgung von Fälschern und Urheberrechtsverletzern.
Zu ACTA müssen wir sicherlich auch nochmal separat unterhalten.
Genau, aber unsere 30 Minuten sind um.
Unsere 30 Minuten sind um, also ACTA ist definitiv so eins der Themen, die wir dann aufgreifen werden, wenn die Nachrichtenlage es uns sozusagen auf den Tisch wirft. Oder vielleicht, wenn ihr, die hier zuhört, uns auch mal den einen oder anderen Hinweis gebt, also gerne in den Kommentaren zu unserer Sendung oder auch über Twitter unter me-netzpolitik, nehmen wir gerne Hinweise und Anregungen entgegen, was denn so in der Woche eurer Auffassung nach vielleicht relevant und damit hier auch auch discussionswürdig war. Ja, und ansonsten machen wir mal eine Sendung, die jetzt in dem abgesteckten Zeitrahmen, den wir uns hier mal vorgenommen haben, auch drin liegt, damit das hier auch alles elegant wegkonsumiert werden kann, während ihr es sonst wieder den 4- oder 5-Stunden-Sendung widmet, die ihr so gerne hört.
Können wir ruhig, also Tim hat mir heute hier mit einem Beamer eine große Uhr an die Wand projiziert und hat gesagt, nur so als unterschwelliger Hinweis, dass man, kannst ja mal draufschauen.
So ein unterschwelliger Hinweis, wie die Gabel, die man in den Rücken gedrückt bekommt. Nee, aber ich meine, das war ja nun trotzdem auch umfangreich. Haben wir es, Linus?
Ich hoffe es.
Super, dann sagen wir Tschüss. Und bis zur nächsten Woche.